i really want to know how to use this
one is it a poking method is it a
smoothing method does it go up your nose
method let's try
yes
it fits hey what's up i'm bella thorne
and today i'm going to be a guest
correspondent for wired
i'm going to be reviewing some fashion
and beauty tech
already first gadget let's see it
oh boy i know what these are
oh i remember when these were the craze
and everyone was like oh my god have you
seen this snapchat well also so cool i
can record you while just wearing
glasses look at me you can't even tell
i'm recording you but it's like
obviously you're recording this blinking
light over here all right let's read
some of these reviews i want to see what
people are saying if you're an avid
snapchat user such as myself then these
things will be a perfect gift for you
my few gripes are that battery life is
frankly terrible and these are way too
pricey he gives it four stars what four
stars out of five without review i just
don't know about those numbers i don't
think that adds up these glasses have
pretty bad pairing issues i can see that
they did not pair with this for 200 i
shouldn't have to be troubleshooting
these things every time i want to upload
a video one star from gerald by the way
for everyone who says i can't read hello
did you guys see me read this for the
first time out loud
i really want to see if they actually
work though because i remember when i
went to the snapchat offices and they
gave me a pair
i tried it and it didn't work and i was
like well this is pointless i don't
understand like what what what is
happening here like uh did it record it
did it work
does anybody know how these things work
anyone because i surely don't
definitely just all the glasses is
better than the first model at least
these look a bit more low-key the other
ones that i saw if i remember correctly
had like yellow and black and really
obvious yeah i give this product zero
stars because the lights turned on i
think that's about all the glasses do
[Music]
well it feels cheap
and flimsy i'm assuming it's supposed to
go like this well definitely some
stimulation for the brain
i'm just feeling really x-men vibes with
this muse too makes meditation easy by
giving you real life feedback on your
mind and body to help you recognize calm
and stay in the zone immersive
soundscapes respond in real time to your
brain activity heart rate body movements
and breathing this feedback guides your
wandering mind to a focused and calm
state
would highly recommend anyone looking to
start meditation or who is looking to go
deeper in a meditation practice five
stars from andrew
bucky and not worth the money i bought
this to relax and now i am more stressed
out about wasting my money
one star from john this does go on your
forehead
so this goes around the back of the ears
i can try and hold it it says to make
sure i'm wearing the headband properly
but i'm i'm clearly not muse's sensors
allow you to discover your mind and body
in a completely unique way
through powerful real-time feedback muse
will help guide you to a deeper
understanding of yourself and your
practice place the rubber ear sensors um
i learned a lot and connected very
deeply with my inner self and my inner
self says i hate meditation
the voice itself was a little annoying
and i just don't know if i'd be able to
meditate with that voice instructing me
what to do he would drive me a little
crazy i know that my fiance is really
big in meditation and i'm sure he'd look
at that as a piece
so out of five stars i would give this
product one star because at least they
had the app part of it working
[Music]
oh
dyson hair wrap i got one of these
upstairs that i've never used because i
don't know how
and it looks too confusing
oh this looks like a huge vibrator yeah
interesting i wonder what all these guys
do
oh
liking this
this is good
not so much
what oh
what are you
dyson air wrap styler no clamping
mechanisms or gloves just voluminous
curls in waves intelligent heat control
measures hair temperature over 40 times
a second to prevent extreme heat damage
while styling amazon customer
it is absolutely the most wonderful
amazing fabulous hair styling blow dryer
i love it i love it i love it i love it
i love it no i'm serious
all those levets are in there don't
waste your money if you have long hair
it don't curl very well and it don't
last two stars from kim
there's a lot of heat coming off
feels like a blow dryer almost to be
honest
no so it uses like airflow to get the
hair around but all you do is just like
and you put it at the end over okay the
thing
and then you see how it wraps there and
now you got a curl
right there
oh yeah
okay
and you you wrap
[Music]
yeah i'm just not gonna spend
this much time
trying to like get this thing working in
the morning
oh good stuff that made a nice wave
very bouncy
so then now that just becomes a blow
dryer
is that it
all right i'm gonna give this one like i
guess four stars because the way that
the package comes together they did a
nice job as far as how it feels how it
looks it feels expensive it feels well
done would i ever use it no probably not
it would probably be too hard too much
work for me to figure out in the morning
if i'm even going to curl my hair you
better know that i am not spending an
extra 30 minutes being like
i'm so
confused why wouldn't it wrap
yeah that won't be me
[Music]
i like the feeling i don't know what you
would call this silicone rubbery
little guy see what he looks like if i
take off his skin
huh oh look
what's happening here
now it's 75. the first social network
for girls who code imagine charm is a
wearable accessory designed for girls to
customize directly from their mobile
phones using programming great way for a
student to learn coding plus they get to
wear the charm five stars from dina look
at what she wrote for the caption here
easy coding fun
explanation point i cannot like this is
definitely the company writing this as a
comment my nine-year-old figured it out
very quickly and then got bored of it
she only played with it for a few days
two stars and then there's animations up
here
i'm sorry you had to learn how to do all
this just for this video yes
oh no
i don't know man i know nothing about
coding uh watermelon getting eaten piece
by piece like my brain is right now
you know at least they got their app
working and stuff i'm gonna give it uh
a three
out of five maybe some little girl out
there really does want to use that piece
[Music]
well it's a high frequency a skin
therapy one with six infusion
applications
yep that's what it says on the box
need support
stop
oh it's a high frequency device
you know when you see those
videos of the girls and they've got that
like weird clothy looking
white thing and then they have this guy
they usually use
for it where is he like this type of
looking thing
and you know they go over it and it
makes a sound jane fonda uses a lot of
high frequency stuff and that has kept
her looking amazing so it should keep us
looking amazing with aging everything
likes to drop right because you're
working against gravity here okay and
there is no really working against
gravity okay so what this does i guess
is it takes all little like fat pockets
and uh what's it called like your muscle
pockets these ones it's supposed to help
like stimulating all the pads in your
face to
kind of stay where they are in a way i
don't really know if it works but all
the instagram girls love it
and jane fonda
oh to
for the scalp
to energize the hair follicles oh
promotes blood circulation
i would use this i've been trying to
grow this
hair out for such a good minute and it
just keeps staying at this god forsaken
middle length high frequency sessions
energize and oxygenate the skin to
increase cellular activity with regular
use you'll notice the reduced appearance
of fine lines and wrinkles over time the
y shape is used for the neck and the
arms
and legs or other areas that are you
ready for this that it can be put in
between
come on but honestly i would really like
to work on this double chin i've been
seeing for the past few months and this
i feel like it's it's it's happening for
it right how much would you guess that
device
i'm assuming it's in the 200 price range
what
all right well now we know it definitely
doesn't work yes you want to buy this i
used to work in spa and used a medical
grade high frequency machine and this is
the same quality for 45 dollars must
have five stars from jj nice i bought it
once two pieces didn't work and returned
it and got a new one one of those same
two pieces still doesn't work one star
from chester maniac
i haven't used this but you know i'm
gonna give this one a good full five
stars okay it probably works
you know ish and i think people should
use it because why would you have to go
spend a thousand dollars a session just
to get some 15 minute high frequency on
your face who has the money to keep up
with that like no no one's doing that
that's too much work i probably wouldn't
use this also a little bit too much work
for me but i'm gonna have to get those
fat pads to stay up some way i am a
gadget i love gadgets i love fun
things to try and see if they work see
if they don't so i had a lot of fun but
i would say if you're going christmas
shopping do not buy any of these things
if you're gonna get them get a gift
receipt
you